the man who plays the chief of staff Ben
Cafferty Kevin Dunne good to see you sir
good to see you very rarely can I turn
to an actor or an actress and say we
have done a movie together we have done
a movie together we did well I mean not
I mean RAF Dade correct so yeah laughter
you know I even asked me if I would do
that film I said well yeah there's not
much of a role there he said yeah but
you get to be on the on the floor during
the draft so I sat with the Browns and
you know it's all it's like equipment
managers and stuff we'll get that job
yeah I'm really trusted this was when it
was in Radio City Music Hall on the
floor radio saying as well so I would
just be writing up players like Ryan
Leaf to actual Browns individuals yet so
at the desk there I was at the desk if
they drafted Ryan Leaf one year like how
the hell did that happen
Rick my roots and it was 2012 it was a
while ago yeah yeah and I kept going for
dares right you have 2012 when we shot
it couple years to come out right went
over to the Bears table repeatedly and
said draft Russell Wilson know you
didn't have trusted you really do that I
saw play twice at Wisconsin when he came
over from was a South Carolina North
Carolina stare like yeah it was just
phenomenal
so they didn't run that up the chain of
command is that we're saying Kevin they
didn't listen well done
who did they draft and some Browns took
Trent Richardson okay finally the Bears
taking the Bears take in 2012 instead of
Russell Wilson which airs took Shane
McClellan defensive end Boise State what
a brain trust if they only listen to you
sir dig take out Sean Jeffery in the
second round he did well he what Wilson
went in the third round he did yeah I
know and now there's Kyler Murray that
can go first overall and a lot of people
think he's worthy of that despite being
510 and 1/8 because of Russell Wilson's
height and dimensions and how well that
he's you know Wilson had and and and and
Marie has incredible presence on the
field he knows where everybody is yeah
you know you can see some quarterbacks
when they come in and they run wild and
you know like rg3 got hurt because he
but they know where the players are I
mean he's just I don't I don't care if
he's five five right he's gonna find a
spot to throw the ball and right you
know and it's pretty cool by the way to
being on a draft floor were you on the
floor but when it actually was really
going I was going on yeah yeah they
muted my headphones and stuff oh okay
yeah I remember you know I shot you know
I shot my seen Kevin Dunn with none
other than Frank Langella okay never
thought I would ever shoot a scene with
Frank Langella in my entire life let
alone meet him okay this is Tony
award-winning yeah oh yeah you know
Academy Award nominated
tour Frank I saw Frank before we started
shooting yeah he's actually said I was
right here back when I won my Tony not
many people can say that sort of thing
so we shot my scene on the second day of
the draft Friday afternoon after
Thursday night the whole first round and
they asked me to wear the same thing
because they shot me on set Thursday
night right they wanted me to wear the
same thing for the shoot on Friday
before the draft so I've got a lot going
on you know for the draft it's a lot
it's a it's a yeah it's a big
assignments crazy it is crazy so I
figured I had like three lines yeah more
than I did I just said at the desk and I
was just like okay if I say anything so
I had three lines and I just figured you
know I'd take a look at him before doing
the scene you know give me ten minutes
before I had no idea Frank Langella was
gonna come on the set just see where
this whole thing was before we're
shooting and he turns to me nice to meet
you and I said nice to meet you sir he
goes would you like to run through our
lines you know I started cursing oh my
god how do I get this stuff together
so we ran through our lines and you do
some warm-ups with fun and just seeing
Costner do his thing in a sports movie
at the end and he's so good at that I
mean he should do all sports films cuz
he's you know he's just kind of a sports
guy he's Kevin cats and cowboys yeah kid
that in cowboys yeah for sure
Kevin done here on the Rich Eisen show
so you're from Chicago yes you would
categorize yourself clearly as a Bears
fan that you're going up to try and
posit that they draft Russell Wilson
third round what do you think of the
current state of the Chicago Bears what
do you what do you think of the way
things are working after making the
playoffs last year well I I can hold I
hope they can hang on to some of their I
hope they can hang on to Callahan and
Amos and right now he was a fifth round
pick he's a great cornerback and you
know they're hard to find but I think
they're in a catbird seat
yeah the North Division has just gets
it's gonna be tough hmm and how does
Green Bay do it I mean it's like half of
our team goes down and you know they're
still gonna always be the Green Bay
Packers
he's got Aaron Rodgers up there yeah
yeah but but I think he I think Maggie's
a good coach I think they need a running
back to slam up the middle and give true
Biscay a little mm you know they got a
good Cohen he's really good too right
yeah they need to figure out how to use
them well they actually I mean they made
the playoffs this year and got the
kicker hitting two pieces of the of the
upright I mean two games were lost
because of that they would have been
playing LA at home right for the NFC
champ
I know and I don't know again you're
your own promotional tour you're you've
got a lot stuff going on I know if
you're aware that the Bears did sign a
new kicker this name blew it I was
texting with my brother and my buddy
last night yeah it was just like drafts
you know bears draft first-round
quarterback auto throw better
is great should we bring up our tea we
actually did this endeavor on our show
yesterday like what could possibly be
the worst names that you can come up
with hypothetically for the position
that they play we did this one out all
night okay so we came up with the
offensive lineman is hold it you don't
want that you don't want the receiver
name drop it yeah you don't need the
what the defensive lineman named trip it
the punters name shanks yeah
can't have shank can't catch well yes
for a wide receiver right oh here it is
right here the defensive back lit up you
don't want to see lit up in your lineup
right
the quarterback picket that's simple and
then somebody told me that when blue it
was on Pittsburgh the quarterbacks name
was in fact Pickett no way yes this is
what somebody was tweeting of me and
then our favorite one was coach Cho kit
for a goalie we had one was empty crease
yeah can it can he pick it how they beat
Clemson that year
pick it and blew it together and then of
course B being a Knick fan the owner's
name is Dolan because he's the worst
owner in sports oh man can't stand him
yeah no he's he's got just problems I
don't know he's got a black cloud he
walks into the garden and it's just like
this what's he gonna do
well I mean look you know a Kevin done
here veep returning HBO at the end of
the month here on the Rich Eisen show
you know what Charles Oakley means to a
team you know he was on the Bulls before
he came to the Knicks
so when Dolan eventually essentially
watched him get dragged out of Madison
Square Garden a couple years ago and let
him rot in jail overnight I was dumb I'm
a diuretic fan yeah done yeah but being
a die-hard Knick fan I do remember all
those years Michael Jordan would rip my
heart out and show it to me pumping I
mean what was it what was it like being
on the the wonderful end of that fan
relationship being with us well you know
you know the Bulls were so bad they used
to play in the amphitheater mmm which
was literally still it was the stockyard
and it was a the floor was laid out and
there were just huge black curtains and
it smelled like cow crap mmm cuz it was
it's not swear they played you know the
password go to bounce it would just
disappear into the darkness of Fame
stockyards from the Sinatra Chicago song
the engines in the Chicago amphitheater
just a horrible place and I mean just
years and years of just really terrible
basketball you know
Erwin Muller and yes right it was just
like you know being in a dream and then
Jordan comes along yeah he just came in
and you know I I we were talking earlier
about LeBron Pass oh yeah he's just
phenomenal and you know one of the best
ever but one thing that Michael Jordan
did that whatever players came along
with the Bulls he made them better
players I mean he just demanded right
and he would give them the ball to win a
game I remember pass the ball off you
know he would you know it just he made
them play so much better than they were
well and and that and it plays into
having my heart ripped out and shown to
be pumping in Madison Square Garden I
will never forget when Jordan scored 55
and combined with Bill Wennington to
score 57 on that night because he passed
off to wedington to win the game
yeah to beat the Knicks and the night
that he had I mean I will never forget
or the nights that he had he combined
with Luc Longley for 57 points in the
end 55 you know I mean that's the pretty
stunning so let's talk veep before you
go gently into that good Los Angeles day
I miss I'm gonna miss it already just as
a fan I have missed it with Julia
louis-dreyfus beating cancer which is
wonderful to see what was it like on the
set for those final seven shows for you
guys i we had so much fun everything
reminded you that it was going to be
this final season huh you know it was
just that kind of okay this is the last
time we're gonna be in this
room or in you know it's that special
yeah it was just I mean we we were in
Baltimore for four years I was there for
three years I came in the second season
so we we really were together all the
time that's where it was shot in
Baltimore man yeah oh yeah because we
didn't we rehearsed a lot with Armando
and his gang of Brit writers we always
rehearse so we didn't never went home so
we were just together all the time and
when we came back to LA it was great
because we didn't have to leave and you
know we were able to sleep in our beds
and be with our families but we had
established that kind of real ensemble
because you know we were cooking you
know hobo stews together and everything
else's you know in the cast back in
Baltimore who was the easiest to crack
up
Tony Tony Hale goes up you know he but
usually so much of the humor between he
and and and and Julia is just this
physical humor that they just pull out
of thin air mm-hm and it almost looks
like a ballet so they they they did each
other in a lot and you know and how much
is this is ad-libbed any of it it's
written okay
uh and rewritten and you know it's very
very inventive curse words like dead
woods the only other show in the history
of maybe television or HBO that had more
inventive curse word servile you know
don't leave them around for your
grandkids to see no they they have
really fertile minds Dave Mendel and his
his band of writers but we do experiment
we do you know throw an alts we
rehearsed a lot in the early years so we
would read a script and then we would
throw the script down and actually go
through this the the show without a
script
mm-hmm and then they would take notes
and rewrite it and this last year was
just a lot of
rights I mean rewrites the day before
the night before the morning before and
right you know it was here new words new
words new pages and she carried the
brunt of that I don't know how she did
it
well she's brilliant she's one of the
greatest yeah comic actors of all time a
great you know like that's why she's
Julia louis-dreyfus hey Kevin really
appreciating you're terrific as well I
can't wait to see this season come back
anytime oh my pleasure
we appreciate it thank you guys it
returns veep to HBO March 31st last
Sunday of this month 10:30 p.m. Eastern
Time 7 glorious episodes can't wait to
see it though Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience